how about this hollywood dream team mark
wahlberg and tom holland they are headed
into uncharted waters in their new movie
that bonded them in real life too
[Music]
your guys chemistry is undeniable mark
what was it like working with tom well
the first time we met we hit it off he
came to visit me in my house we uh we
have so much in common i mean ditto
really
the film was was tough to make
i think physically for for the pair of
us it was it was a very demanding film
but we're lucky to have each other as a
kind of team to to lean on each other
does a movie like spider-man help you
coming into this with spider-man i've
always been able to wear a mask you're
able to disguise certain things and and
cg can enhance things here and there
whereas in this film we really had to
push the limits of what we could do
et has this exclusive look behind the
scenes of mark and tom's new action
adventure mark in a chopper both crammed
in a trunk and this sequence dangling
100 feet up in the air tom says it's the
toughest stunt he's ever done
[Applause]
but this moment was the most terrifying
silly
hurry we're gonna drown
they built
this massive set they would drop it into
the water and it would
sink and we would go down with it and
you'd obviously be holding your breath
and then there was a hole out the back
side of it and we would swim out of that
hole and obviously up to the surface
and it was awful
you're doing great
tom and mark go up against antonio
banderas on the hunt for the lost
treasure in uncharted hitting theaters
february 18th uncharted in real life for
mark being the dad of an 18 year old
with a boyfriend a beautiful post to
your daughter what is it like for you
to watch your kids just turn into young
adults just proud of them that they're
making choices on their own you want
them to stay young forever my wife
really has a hard time with them kind of
getting older she'd like to you know
keep them little forever but you know
they're uh they're wonderful children
[Music]
you